yeah one more one more
for mythic rank baby oh boy
I had it one time I lost two mana rent
this is not the best opening hand but
let's just hope we're not playing mana
red oh of course
if there's one day yeah good game shut
the [ __ ] up
I literally said hey don't play against
Monterrey so I'm not playing as angry
white people anymore I'm playing as
angry white lamin because I think most
of these women yeah sure sure you know
what I don't even look at gender I look
at people but we're playing an angel
deck it's really annoying how effective
this dumbass deck is because it it ain't
shape it's just really strong cards
that's all it is
there's no finance there's no secret
this is an overall good deck and that's
really all you need
unfortunately you can play your players
and mythical names our arena team
members cheating okay
mr. Brightside let's look on it mr.
Brightside please just let me win one
this is not an ideal starting hand it's
actually kind of [ __ ] but I don't think
I can afford anything up at least I can
play Banali I turn three god it's not
gonna be good at it god no stop that's
fine
uh-huh what else you got you got nothing
you pathetic your uh god I hate that
carnage soap you know P dude honestly
well I hope you enjoyed having it kids
now you're gonna eat my ass I cannot
afford taking five damage this early
all right k heck screw damn we are
getting stomped boys okay we need a
Phoenix in here ASAP
that's right why don't you attack oh I'm
so scared oh why don't you attack them
why don't you attack them baby
another Phoenix Oh but you weren't
expecting that were you attack then do
it all you want all stump no removal oh
oh I feel for you buddy
I honestly do except I don't this is a
win I can smell it now we're just gonna
make sure I write make the right move
here because I can give a trample I
don't want to give anything trample I
was gonna be vigilance I don't know if
then they pointed playing or really at
this turn I want to really out though
yeah let's get a really all that being a
[ __ ] and we're gonna show just how
confident we are by actually attacking
that's trying what you can attack me
it's fine do it
Oh bye-bye oh there it is
hell yeah I never thought I would do it
that's awesome
that feels amazing angry white woman it
works this dick just works it's really
annoying
how well it works you try to stomp on me
I flump on you okay get flunked well
there's some more matches
I just wanted to film myself getting
this okay yes let's play a bit more I am
I think this might be fun for me to
maybe just talk a bit more in general
and I can not be so tri Hardy let's play
some mythic rank yeah
so a lot of people were very excited by
my last video about magic which I did
not expect whatsoever to be honest I'm
surprised how many people actually play
the game themselves I think that's
really cool like I said I played it when
I was a was a kid I think I was a bit
too young and this is not a good hand oh
well I think I was a bit too young when
I played it no mana red great phenomenal
so I didn't really understand the game
too much but I remember my mom would
always take me to the to the store that
where they stole magic cards so you
could play with other people because she
thought if I if I played with other
people then that's better than me
playing online or playing video games I
guess I'm not sure if this is the right
move he's playing a goblin deck I should
be fine I played against goblin decks
before and I absolutely stumped them but
this is not a good start and I don't
have good drawers so he's probably
sitting on something and I'm still gonna
block it just for this sake actually I'm
not [ __ ] he's gonna get spectacle which
I really don't want so I'm just gonna
try and stop that I should have played
to the taker first but I know he's gonna
hit me up with something anyway okay
we're gonna love a core [ __ ] out of that
cuz I don't like it god I got alright
[Music]
I need to organize my cards better and
we're not gonna attack so far we're in
round three and we have not taken any
damage which is very good against mono
red obviously he doesn't seem like oh
and the problem is I don't have the
cards I just don't have the cards he's
gonna probably shock me if he doesn't
I'll be a happy boy
why didn't he write oops hello
[Music]
whoa Wow he must be some sort of genius
whoa how did he think of doing that
listen buddy I'm fine
we have lira which it's my girl she's my
girl I love her
this is good I don't care as long as
you're not playing spells okay all right
don't give him a lightning bolt actually
we're fine for fine hello Lyra what's up
what's up boo what's up
well attack and see if they do a trade
which they won't but at least I can do
some damage don't my Lyra you do not
[ __ ] my Lydia he's not gonna attack any
more at this point actually I mean if he
does he's stupid he's great please
attack if he attacks now I'll be a happy
boy
do what you gotta do here ago hello
ain't got time so what's your plan here
he has to play I just realized he has to
play the lava coil this turn otherwise
he loses it oh look he did it
congratulations you did the moon nice
Wow
took you long enough Jesus Christ now
here's the problem he could be sitting
on thunderbolt he could be sitting on a
lot of things I'm gonna risk it just cuz
you can't be a [ __ ] all your life he
doesn't have anything phenomenal
good to know we get 5 life they lose my
life I was the best thing that could
happen
what is his battle plan you gonna play
the risk factor do it play the risk
factor you're gonna play it play your
risk factor do it play it play it play
it no you're gonna attack wow what a
good move do it oh no don't attack
all right well blocks we took healthy
I'll take 3 damage what an idiot
oh you're gonna eat ass tonight boys boy
I mean maybe there's two boys playing
what are you gonna do
what are you gonna do oh hello hello oh
do you think that's nice you ain't seen
nothing yet why did you attack last turn
your dumb ball you feel a bum why don't
you go and play mana read in your
underwear you oh come on where's the
aggro play the risk factor oh nice wow
what a great
good job oh gee I wonder what I'm gonna
do oh it doesn't affect by two Kelty mmm
where's the brain let em oh there you go
nice good game oh come on
oops look at that cute mono read one
more game one more game I wasn't
recording okay sorry it didn't hit
record
oopsie-doopsie thank you for telling me
what a nag road that gaze thank you very
much
Wow I had no idea chip where you're
gonna become shipping whatever okay shut
up
Oh God hey Jesus hey I get to start
first time ever never happened into this
game before what are you guys you got
green it's the count the time
what's that time of year why don't you
play your Explorer Oh green red all
right fine I don't care I don't care I
don't care I don't care I literally
don't care I don't care your turn buddy
what do you got what do you have in your
hand
it's got land
that's pretty good lanes are pretty good
all right well we know he's playing we
know his threat to Jim oh I need another
for rekindling that's fine we draw
irelia we drew a Roley at borealis as
question is that we buff him for the
sake of attacking it doesn't really make
a difference yeah we might as well
because he's gonna have to force to
block or we just happened to hit his
face for for which I will take and then
next turn even if he blocks it we can
mentor the flyer we get forward to the
face I'll take it and he can add he can
adapt [ __ ] I've been thinking about that
well even if it did at that they would
still have died if we can get rekindling
feelings out that would be amazing he
saves to mana to do what exactly
that is our kindling Phoenix
well plate will pay the life to get
rekindling Phoenix out now I would
prefer to use angel a little grace to be
honest but I want to use it as a
surprise
ello surprise party so we can pretty
much hit for free now or damaged really
nice we're gonna have to if we keep this
up this is an easy win we'll see how he
responds that's fine
sure sure whatever whatever
alright I'll block it you know he's a
coward you know my boys a coward if
that's all you got nice oh we are making
good drawers I completely forgot my own
strategy do you think it will attack
next turn I feel like he's gonna [ __ ]
out did we play an angel or not because
then next turn we have six money we
don't have six money we're fine mana I'm
gonna actually just do this because we
can keep heading for him for free oh you
know what let's attack we both
his next turn he's dead
hello what do you got all right we can
roulette that result so we have a couple
options here so obviously I think
probably what I want to do is I want to
just get rid of actually we'll see what
happens
we won already basically it doesn't
really matter what we do I'm just
curious what he thinks he can do how
nice oh nice alright let's see what
happens he attacks with everything four
five six seven eight nine ten eleven
twelve twelve damage
I mean it's gg hello hello hello concede
concede and let's block base and I mean
could you sit on something else
nice like this unless block this doesn't
matter cuz Phoenix will finish the job
next turn anyway well that's a dick move
to make
Wow nice you did it now let's just for
the sake of being a dick
yeah nice hello Oh thinking oops
bye 93 percent I'm literally going
backwards and I act like a 12 year old
hope you guys enjoyed another episode of
Magic the Gathering it was fun have
happy times basically I don't know if I
said it but I got up to Diamond rank one
with angry white people I just couldn't
get to mythic with it and I decided
because everyone is mano reading and
it's so annoying it's not the best
against it obviously it has Clarion but
I'm really happy I'm really glad I got
to mythic so next up we're gonna go for
invitational top eight no problem
whatsoever see you guys there and smash
like subscribe goodbye